in other news iran's president-elect has
declared his country has many more
foreign policy objectives than just
reviving the
nuclear deal with world powers
ibrahimovic gave his first news
conference
since winning friday's election he did
reiterate his support for that agreement
but said he wasn't prepared to meet u.s
president joe biden
reichi reisi emphasized it was the u.s
that violated the deal by withdrawing
three years ago
our interaction with all countries will
be balanced any negotiation that is
going to be the benefit of our nation
will be supported
but negotiations should have an
achievement for the great nation of iran
and its people
[Music]
our stance is that all signatories
should return to the 2015 agreement
and abide by their commitments we are
asking the europeans not to be pressured
or influenced by the americans
our people want their rights to be
revived
let's hear from our correspondents on
this first dorsa jabari following
developments from tehran
i think at this point he's laying out
very early on
he's hedging his bets in case this
nuclear deal doesn't happen
he doesn't want to be responsible or
accountable for that i think he's
playing it very very safe
he's saying there are a lot of other
issues namely he also
made a reference to iran's relationship
with regional powers including saudi
arabia
and the ongoing war in yemen he said
that those issues are something the
iranians
are willing to move forward on including
the fact that iran does not have any
issues with saudi arabia that they
are willing to sit down with them and
reestablish ties that is something that
the previous administration
has also hinted at in terms of yemen he
mentioned the fact that the
solution for the war in that country
needs to come from the yemeni people
themselves
but when it came to the nuclear deal
which dominated most of the questions
from foreign media
at his first press conference he was
adamant that this is a
ongoing issue that iran is willing to
um go back to its original commitments
if the united states
returns to the deal and lifts the
sanctions he said as long as there is a
benefit for the iranian nation there
he will he doesn't see any issues with
honoring
this agreement of course this comes at a
critical time because
there's a lot of speculation about what
this new government who will take office
in august
will do in terms of the nuclear deal but
there's a push from vienna now
that there needs to be some kind of
resolution soon these talks cannot be
ongoing indefinitely
and now our white house correspondent
kimberly halcott on how washington's
reacted
to gracie's win well in some ways the
white house is probably relieved given
the fact at least now there
is an outcome in terms of these
elections there has been sort of a
collective holding of breath waiting for
that
because it really was impossible to move
forward until they knew
who specifically they were dealing with
moving forward so now there is
resolution on that but the
hard work begins because iran has made
it no secret what it's looking for and
that is
a lifting of those extremely punishing
sanctions
and that is something that the united
states up until now has not been
prepared to do having said that
the united states as part of trying to
revive this deal this 2015 agreement to
limit iran's nuclear program that the
trump administration the previous
administration
withdrew from uh there have been signs
of good
faith but it appears that that has not
been enough for example
there has been a quiet lifting of some
sanctions that
affect businesses as well as certain
individuals the state department's
saying
this is because those businesses or
individuals were in compliance
with u.s federal laws and understandings
and so as a result those were lifted
but that did not sit well with some
house congressional republicans who are
now
calling for oversight accusing the white
house of acting without
congressional authority so there are
complicated issues here in the united
states for joe biden moving forward
the big concern for iran is that there
has to be some trust shown by the united
states how does iran know
that the united states and a successive
government after the biden
administration
may live up or may not live up to its
words as we saw with the trump
administration